what we're going to do today is we're
going to do a lot of discussing I hope
because
um I'm going to try
to empty my
head and give it to you and a lot of you
after lunch might go home thinking
whatever was that it's I'm not going to
be talking about anything spiritual I'm
going to be talking about gut feeling
intuition and um how I see I
uh let's I'll just ask a question who's
been doing iido less than 20 years less
than 20 years okay so we
got five
people so so you'll have to do the best
you
can but when I say do the best you can
you see most of
us what what I had this sort of
Revelation come to me that
we look at ensi and we all I think want
to be like ensi or get as close as we
can to ense
Psy and there cyto Sensi saying look
these are the techniques ensi taught me
but what happens is we're doing these
techniques in hopes that we're going to
get to
ensi but they're nothing if you could
show me a film where you see ensi doing
a technique
I need to see it because I've never seen
one so what I'm going to do today is I'm
going to try and empty my head and tell
you how I see iido because I want to try
and give you that
bridge so that you can understand there
you go from here to
here a lot of what I say might seem
arrogant but
please I'm telling you now I don't mean
it in that way I'm just very blunt
person and I say
how I say
it what I really want to do is I want to
help you understand that doing technique
is a must because without perfect
technique you cannot make the
leap and I don't think I'm anywhere near
an no Sensi but I I think that I
understand how to get on that other
side the next thing I'm going to say and
it might sound very
arrogant but I want to ask you don't
have to put your hands up but I want to
ask any of you have you reached your
goal yet in
iido if anybody says yes then come out
here and
[Music]
you I've reached my goal it came to me
last
year because what I realized was the
techniques I don't like I don't do
anymore the techniques I like but I
can't get them why am I trying
anymore um so by shedding stuff you
actually become free and when cyto sensy
passed away he let me out of a prison
see I was in this prison of wanting to
be and do everything that he wanted me
to do and I wanted to mimic him and I
wanted to be his good student when he
died I remember the words in my head
when he said Tony please develop Ken and
Joe keep me war or iido safe you see but
he let me out the prison because he's
not here now to tear me off so I can I
can do what I
want so today I want you to be as honest
as me and to ask questions I want you to
say I don't get it or what are you
talking about so we're going to be doing
a lot of the time we're going to be
doing Tech mov movement rather than
techniques uh I've got a load of notes
I'm hoping that they'll come to me but
let's just say if you haven't reached
your goal yet but I have how have I
reached this
goal I've swapped round my
thinking you've been hearing me for
years I
um please go past so I made room for for
John or if he does a show
minich please go past and you've heard
me say this for
years what I realized
was I'm actually UK and not nay but in
my thinking I'm UK because what I'm
doing is I'm genuinely saying please go
past at first they just words and then
they become
meaningful because what I realized
without un without
um so as he
comes I'm there right so watch watch
where I am I didn't choose where I went
I was John chose it for me because I'm
UK If I Was
nag I'd come up here and I'd go what
I've got his I've got is ready for a
cut so what I want you to do is with
each person I want you
to I want you to
move and do what I'm doing so I'm going
to show you for instance if you don't
get it I can't answer over these
questions but if you don't get it I want
you to say I don't get that because to a
lot of you you might go home today
thinking i't got a clue what he's on
about but you might be walking down the
street in a year's time and go I
understand a bit of that so let can I
have a volunteer uh can I I've got a
volunteer but can I have a volunteer to
so I yeah right so so what just to show
you so John's going to do that and
you're going to do what I done you're
just going to take it out the way right
now I'm going to ask Ray don't don't
move so we're going to ask now do you
feel too close to
him not really I I feel I feel all right
so ra got it completely wrong all right
but but I've got to be honest
because you think that you feel too
close to
him now what I'm talking about here so I
explain it what I'm talking about here
is I'm talking about
intuition that
feeling does as a person to another
person
if you were in the street would you feel
too close to him yeah
yeah right so Ray needs to work out how
he can move and not feel too did you
say so he's got it now so we're going to
do it
again what do you reckon do you do he
feel too close to you no no do you feel
too close to him no not depending on
what I'm doing yeah ah you're thinking
technical
now right so this is thinking
technical can I can can any of you we
see he's actually too close to him can
any of you see there's nothing wrong
here look the arms nicely placed how is
he so they both going stay there stay
there and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to ask John now to push to
right
okay he should F not a hard wall but a
soft wall all right so push
again okay so what Ray is doing is he's
thinking in himself and he's and he's
you know he's he's sort making what call
he's creating mass and he's creating
mass with his
mind so in other words he doesn't want
to be
defeated so this is because we don't
want to be defeated so he's
not okay at all he's in control so he's
n when I do it I don't feel so so just
move back a little
bit okay I want you to move back to the
point where you actually don't feel like
you got control but you're still there
so you're on the edge that's it so
you're on on the edge that